let's try a little experiment I want you
to read the first paragraph of Alice's
adventure and wonderland out loud it's a
little weird right with only a few words
per line it's kind of awkward to read
words or phrases that might be read as
groups end up getting broken across
multiple lines making it hard to parse
the sentences why don't you try this one
instead it's got a few more words for
line so maybe we won't have the same
problem it's the same content but with
more words and it still doesn't work if
a line of text is too long readers get
lost when trying to find the next line
and end up reading the same thing over
and over again or they get lazy and
might read the first part of each line
but by the end they're skimming over the
last century there's been lots of
research done to determine the ideal
measure that's the technical term for
the length of a line I've seen research
ranging from 45 characters per line to
as many as 90 characters per line
depending on the font used if it's in
print if it's projected or on a computer
screen but there seems to be a pretty
solid consensus around 65 characters per
line for the web it's not a hard and
fast rule but it's a good place to start
we need to consider the way people read
as we create our designs since it can
affect our layout that's why line length
is an important factor to consider as
you're building sites and something i
always take into consideration as i
choose my break points it's also
important to make sure that fonts are
big enough to read across any device I
always set my base font to at least 16
pixels and at least a 1.2 e.m line
height depending on the situation I may
even increase it for text heavy sites 14
pixels is just too small that may sound
big but makes for a much better reading
experience even on a desktop it works
quite well